Today's challenge is to play on an inclined table.
We have got three setups for you guys
Let's try them out!
A bit more
There we go
Yeah, there we go!
Okay, this is already quite steep!
Miikka is just not tall enough
We have to go steeper
I don't know what's like the...
I don't know what's happening!
Okay, we are going to make it work
There must be a way
But how can we keep the game going?
Like this
It actually works!
I can already now say that there
is no point in this
Yeah, this is the way
Hello there!
Hello!
Yeah now it is fun!
Jackpot!
At least you gave me a warning!
Let's do one more setup
and do it sideways
It just looks really broken!
That was a roller!
The first setup was quite fun
but these two last ones didn't really work so good
Third one was actually quite ok
but probably not as fun as the first one
Anyway, remember to help our channel
and subscribe here
and watch our previous episodes there
Until next time!